what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched the
first episode of she-hulk right away let
me know in the comments down below what
you thought of the first episode did you
like it did you not like it what did you
think of the overall tone really curious
to hear your thoughts on this now of
course we are going to talk about all of
the important scenes of this episode but
there are two very important things that
we have to talk about first and that is
one it looks like jennifer walters aka
she-hulk is going to be a very prominent
character in the new avengers and two
this show is definitely setting up a
solo hulk movie and it was really really
cool to see she hulk and the hulk on
screen together it was such a fun time
so let's not waste any time let's dive
into it the first thing that we have to
talk about is the fact that she-hulk is
going to go on to become a new avenger
the world premiere launch event for
she-hulk was monday august 15th i got
the opportunity to attend it was a lot
of fun but of course during this time
actors do interviews and one thing that
mark ruffalo actually said was that
there's not going to be a new avengers
team without she-hulk moving forward
which is really really cool we obviously
know that we have two new avengers films
coming in 2025 and as we're about to end
phase four and go into phase five and
phase six we are going to start to see
the new avengers team actually come
together now in she-hulk episode 1 much
doesn't really happen concerning
villains of she-hulk we do see her
briefly take on titania and defeat
titania at the end of episode 1 but of
course this is about the origin story of
how jennifer walters becomes she-hulk
and how she doesn't really want to be a
hulk and she doesn't want to be a
superhero in fact she tells bruce banner
this her cousin she says i'm not gonna
be a superhero and she states that she
just wants to be a lawyer however i
think we know how this story goes it's a
typical with great power comes great
responsibility line and this is
essentially what bruce banner was
telling her that they can't act like
they're one of the two only people out
of only a handful of actual superheroes
who can protect the earth he's basically
telling her that because she has the
power to protect the earth it is kind of
her responsibility to do so so right now
it kind of seems like we know how this
is going to end a classic superhero arc
jennifer walters is going to go through
a bunch of different trials during these
nine episodes she will fight villains
and she will fight being a superhero but
also having her personal life but at the
end i think we ultimately know that
she's probably going to accept the fact
that she's a superhero and can help and
of course given what mark ruffalo said
about the future of she-hulk it looks
like we are going to be seeing a lot of
hurt down the road in the avengers
movies but we can also expect to see a
hulk movie at least we hope it's a movie
and not a disney plush show there have
been rumors going around about a world
war hulk movie and this first episode
actually backs up those rumors that
marvel studios is indeed setting up a
solo hulk story in this episode we see
the ship from sakaar actually caused the
accident that caused jennifer walters to
ultimately become she-hulk now of course
i talked about this and a lot of other
outlets talked about this as well when
marvel studios first released this clip
several days ago it was very clear that
this ship was from sakaar as it looks
almost identical to the grand master
ship the only thing that is different
than what we saw in thor ragnarok was
the paint but one thing that marvel
studios did not show us was after the
accident where jennifer walters goes
into bruce's lab and asks if they hit an
alien spaceship in which bruce banner
replies with yeah a sequarian class a
courier craft he says they were probably
trying to deliver a message and that he
has to get to the bottom of that this is
all extremely interesting and it's
actually pretty revealing one is bruce
banner knows exactly what this spaceship
is he even knows the class of it this
shows us that he has clearly come in
some sort of contact with sakhar since
he was there on thor ragnarok if you
take a look at thor ragnarok and you
watch the scene where the hulk turns
back into bruce banner bruce banner has
no idea what's going on he doesn't know
where zakar is he didn't even know that
he was on another planet he didn't
remember anything after the events of
avengers age of ultron in fact he didn't
even know how it all ended he asked if
sokovia was okay then he is with thor
the rest of the time and he leaves
giving him no time to learn pretty much
anything let alone the exact
specification of a ship from sakhar this
tells us that bruce banner has been in
contact with sakhar and maybe has even
been back and i'm guessing that he has
been back i actually think that he
probably spent some time during the blip
over at zakar and i don't think that the
sicarian ship was actually being hostile
as bruce banner states they were
probably trying to deliver a message
which is another indicator that he's
probably been back to sakhar and has
probably done some good things as
they're trying to get in contact with
him and we specifically know that this
ship does not have guns on it if they
were trying to be hostile they would
have sent a ship with guns so this is
all a clear build up towards a hulk solo
project heck we could even be going down
the comic story line where the hulk
actually has a son scar after all we
don't know what the hulk did during that
entire time that he was there in sakaar
two years but we do know he was a
champion and might have mated with
somebody it's actually pretty probable
that he did so perhaps we're about to be
introduced to the hulk's son so that's
going to be a fun hulk story that
hopefully we dive into pretty soon now
getting back to she-hulk there are many
awesome scenes in this episode so let's
dive into it the episode opens up with
jennifer walters deputy district
attorney working for the da's office
prepping her closing statement for a
court that she is about to go to with
her is her best friend and paralegal
nikki ramos and also another lawyer that
works at her office dennis bukowski who
is basically there just to be a
douchebag and try to undermine her and
he is basically who she is talking about
later on where she explains to her
cousin that she controls her anger all
the time when incompetent men tell her
how to do her area of expertise so they
leave her office to go to court but she
jumps back in her office to break the
fourth wall and talk to us this is
something that she-hulk does in the
comics she breaks the fourth wall just
like deadpool she then tells us yeah i'm
a hulk and we proceed into her origin
story cut to her and her cousin bruce
banner going on a road trip together
first thing to notice here is that bruce
banner explains that the device on his
wrist is a prototype that he designed to
keep himself from turning into the hulk
later on he does go on to explain that
it was a prototype and was the only one
in the first one that he built so he
can't simply make another one for jen to
keep her from turning into her hulk form
of course jen is talking about all of
the evidence and the research that she
has done leading her to believe that
steve rogers was a virgin which we know
and is revealed in the post-credits
scene that he is indeed not and i did
really love that credit scene it did
genuinely make me laugh but ultimately
like we have talked about the sicarian
ship shows up and this causes them to
crash here is where jennifer walters's
origin story is changed in the mcu after
the crash jennifer walters gets out of
the car she ends up cutting her arm on a
piece of bent metal she has a huge cut
on her arm and she is bleeding when she
pulls bruce banner out of the car he is
bleeding as well and some of his blood
actually goes into the cut of jennifer's
mixing his blood with her blood giving
her what he says was a lethal dose of
gamma radiation which in turn causes her
to turn into she-hulk bruce banner
actually explains that their dna is very
specific and special and has a lot of
unique factors that actually let them
synthesize gamma radiation so those
genes run in their family which is why
the two of them cousins can both be
hulks now this is a cool mcu origin
story but in the comics it's actually a
little bit different jennifer walters
was an attorney already and she was
defending a client who was at odds with
a person named nicholas trask so
nicholas trask hired people to kill
jennifer however on that same day bruce
banner was actually visiting his cousin
jennifer the people end up shooting
jennifer but bruce banner is there to
rescue her and take her to a hospital
where he decides that she needs a blood
transfusion so some of his blood goes
into her to save her life which results
in her becoming the hulk so there's a
lot of similarities here but there's
also a little bit of a difference
between the car accident and people
trying to kill her but the origin of her
basically getting bruce banner's blood
and becoming the she-hulk because of
that is essentially the same now we kind
of see her hulk out for the first time
here when the blood gets inside of her
wound but we don't fully see it until
she finds herself outside of the bar she
meets some friendly woman who help her
out and give her some nice clothes and
when she's going to the bathroom you can
actually see something that marvel has
been doing a lot of recently in their
disney plus shows and you can see a qr
code on the wall if you scan this
barcode on your phone it will take you
to marvel.com where you can read a free
she-hulk comic that inspired the series
that is now streaming on disney plus
that we just watched and when she's
waiting outside for her cousin bruce to
come pick her up we see some guys come
out who say ladies night was a bust
meaning they didn't really have any game
and didn't get with any women however
they see jennifer outside and they are
really really pressing her they keep
pressing her and she feels threatened so
of course she turns into she-hulk but
right before she does anything bruce
banner as the hulk jumps on her and
restrains her we cut back to bruce's
place in mexico jen wakes up and looks
for bruce and actually when she's going
to look for bruce she stumbles upon what
looks to be an old iron man helmet that
or either it is an old iron legion
helmet but what's really cool is that
when jennifer actually sees the helmet
you can hear the old avengers theme play
in the background an awesome and epic
easter egg here and it fits perfectly
into this episode as bruce consistently
brings up tony stark reinforcing the
fact that they were best friends science
bros now jen eventually finds bruce
banner down in his lab back in hulk form
or as he calls it smart hulk which is
something that fans actually termed and
it's funny that they actually do kind of
address that and kind of break the
fourth wall here when bruce says you
don't really have a say in what people
call you which is clever because the
fans are the ones who originally started
calling him smart hulk that and
professor hulk now what's really funny
is that smart hulk goes on to explain
that the lab was given to him by tony
stark his friend probably his best
friend and you can tell that he's proud
of that he says tony tony stark and he
gets a little grin on his face but then
he jokes about how tony said it was a
loner and that at any moment in time he
could sweep by and pick it all up again
and you can actually see the sadness on
his face when he says that because of
course now sadly tony is gone and you
can tell by the look on his face that he
misses him here we actually learned that
the hulk uses jennifer's blood to fix
his own arm clearly their blood and
genes are actually a little bit
different they do have the same factors
that allow them to synthesize gamma
radiation but it does seem like gins
does it a little bit better or at least
differently because as we find out when
jyn turns into she-hulk she actually
retains her consciousness and she is
still in control very different than
bruce banner and the hulk they are two
different people but it looks like jyn
and she hulk are actually kind of the
same person the only thing that changes
is her body and of course her strength
and everything that comes with being
she-hulk but her consciousness is
totally intact and she is totally in
charge not wrestling with a she-hulk as
a different person but she herself is
still the same person which blows bruce
spanner's mind away now bruce tells her
that there's no way she's going back to
a normal life after this she is now a
hulk and he tells her that she's
basically going to have to change her
entire life but jennifer walters has
been set on being a lawyer for a very
long time she finally graduated past the
bar exam has her own office working at
the da's office right now and there's no
way that she's not going back to that
and bruce is essentially saying that she
can't because she needs to keep her
anger in check because her turning into
the hulk jeopardizes a lot of people's
safety so she basically needs to stay
there so bruce can run some tests to
figure out really what makes her tick
and turn into she-hulk however after
doing a bunch of these tests they
realize that jyn can control it she can
turn into she-hulk when she wants to and
she can actually turn back when she
wants to so the threat of a true hulk
bursting out and raging and not having
any control whatsoever and doing
destruction and harm to other people
that's not really there the threat of
that isn't there because jyn ultimately
has control and actually at a point in
the comics jennifer walters actually
prefers to remain in she-hulk form for a
long time now when she's with bruce
banner here in mexico and they're trying
to figure out how she turns into
she-hulk and how exactly she is as a
she-hulk there are some really cool
references and easter eggs when they are
trying to determine how she-hulk can
turn back into jennifer walters she
asked smart hulk how when he was the
hulk he would turn back into bruce
banner here bruce says usually i'd fall
out of a jet or get knocked out by a
robot and i'd wake up as banner now the
first part falling out of the jet is a
reference to the very first avengers
film where the hulk hulked out on the
carrier he jumped on a fighter plane and
eventually jumped off and landed on
earth he awakened as bruce banner the
second part is the ultron fight in
avengers age of ultron and of course he
goes on to talk about natasha singing
him a lullaby which we saw in avengers
age of ultron as well and it's really
funny that he can't actually explain how
the lullaby would bring him back into
bruce banner form however i think we all
know it's because of the love so
jennifer tries to conclude that being
unconscious is the key to turning back
into human form however bruce goes on to
explain that one time he was the hulk
for two years and of course we know that
that was the time of thor ragnarok and
during that time he saw a previously
recorded message of natasha talking to
bruce banner and that's what turned the
hulk back into bruce we then have a
montage of bruce banner essentially
training jennifer on how to be a hulk we
see them throwing boulders and getting
really competitive with each other and
then bruce decides to show her the
positives of being a hulk here we cut to
bruce banner's bar where he's making
drinks and he says that their bodies
metabolize alcohol at an incredibly fast
rate which means they can't get drunk
this is actually a callback to steve
rogers captain america from the first
captain america film where he's trying
to get drunk after bucky dies and agent
peggy carter comes in and captain
america says he can't get drunk and
peggy carter explains that his
metabolism is essentially four times
faster than a normal human being's and
they actually mentioned steve rogers
here jennifer says you built this with
your own hands and smart hulk says yeah
me and tony well tony mostly sat around
and drank and complained about steve but
again this shows how close bruce and
tony were and this was during the five
year blip and on the bar we can actually
see the initials of bruce banner bb and
of course tony stark ts later on after
the hulk and she-hulk have a fight and
break brees banners bar they go in to
fix it and jennifer carves her own
initials into the bar jw jennifer
walters now the next day jen wakes up
and realizes that when she reverts back
to her human form she actually does feel
the hangover they then go on to some
meditation where the hulk tries to tell
her that she needs to control her anger
in which jennifer replies that she does
it all the time she does it when guys
cat call her when people try to explain
her job to her when she's clearly much
better at it than they are and she even
seemingly gets mad while she's
explaining this to bruce and turns into
she-hulk and bruce goes aha there you go
but jennifer says i did that myself i
turned it to the she-hulk and then she
changes back into jennifer and she did
this as a point to prove to bruce that
she is actually in control of her hulk
form and there isn't much of a threat to
society because she is fully in control
when she is she-hulk therefore she can
go back home now ultimately she ends up
trying to go back home in which of
course bruce tries to stop her which
leads to a hulk fight which i am
extremely grateful for because it was
really awesome and we got to see she
hulk hulk out but we also got to see
hulk's thunderclap something i truly
enjoyed and she hulk has a thunderclap
of her own it's not as big it doesn't
blast people away however it is severely
damaging to the ears which ultimately
causes bruce banner to fall to the floor
now i don't think either hulk was fully
hulking out here especially bruce banner
i know we're all waiting for the true
hulk to come out and burst out with rage
but bruce seem to be keeping it pretty
together here and ultimately the two of
them end up falling on the bar that
bruce and tony built which of course
bumps bruce out stops the fight both of
them know what the bar means to bruce
and bruce tells jennifer she's fixing it
then we cut to the two of them fixing it
bruce begrudgingly says that she can go
back to new york and continue her life
in which jennifer looks at us breaks the
fourth wall and says he doesn't mean
that and what's interesting here is that
it kind of seems like bruce
smart hulk can kind of hear her which is
interesting now we don't know if he just
hears her talking to nobody but maybe
they'll address this in the future
ultimately jennifer leaves to go back
home and the two of them do end on good
terms with bruce telling his cousin the
door is always open for her to come back
we go back to her current life we see
her in court and titania bust into the
courtroom right before jennifer is about
to deliver her closing argument her best
friend and paralegal nikki tells her
it's time to do her thing it's time to
become she-hulk which is something
jennifer didn't want to do she didn't
want the whole world knowing but
ultimately she knows it's the right
thing to do and nikki even mentions
civil duty again kind of going back to
with great power comes great
responsibility she turns into she-hulk
and everybody is shocked including
titania who asks who the hell she is
titania attacks not only her but the
jury in which she hulk defends them she
catches the deaths that titania throws
at them throws it back at her and when
titania jumps at her true mortal combat
style she-hulk gives her a big punch to
the stomach knocking her down and that
is how we end episode 1 except for that
amazing post credit scene jennifer
walters tricked her cousin bruce banner
making him think that she was drunk so
she could truly find out if captain
america steve rogers was a virgin in
which he reveals he wasn't and it's also
nice to know that we're still talking
about america's butt now quick note
about titania in the comics she actually
gets her powers from dr doom during
secret wars which we know is coming and
it's been rumored that doctor doom is
going to be coming as early on as this
year so hopefully there is a doctor doom
connection there but that is it for
episode one let me know what you thought
about it in the comments down below and
let me know what your favorite part of
this show was please don't forget to
like this video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things mcu and
she-hulk for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof